it gets easier right these are the words
I often hear from young parents who are
new to the game of worrying about their
children I tell them that it doesn't it
gets different but there's always
something to worry about as parents I
remember how I would lie half awake at
night listening to my son breathe when
he was young and had asthma and then
when he was a teen until I heard the
front door chime open and I knew that he
was home safe worrying about our kids
comes with the territory now many of
these varèse are about basic issues like
what they eat where they are who they
are with but we also need to keep an eye
on new behaviors and fads the latest
craze is something that may not yet be
on everyone's radar as a serious health
concern and that is the newfound
popularity of vaping or inhaling sweet
air ourselves produced by vaporizing a
liquids in e-cigarettes a cigarettes or
vapes as they are commonly called are
flying off the shelves like candy this
year the e-cigarette market is expected
to drive twenty six billion dollars in
sales worldwide over the next six years
that volume is expected to double we
have a lot of serious concerns about the
health impact of vaping and
unfortunately not nearly enough answers
this becomes even more concerning when
you think of who uses a cigarette
Ystad reduce at least in the US has
grown rapidly among youth and young
adults our kids our most vulnerable
population there was a 900 percent
growth in the use of e-cigarettes by
youth between 2012 and 2015 the most
recent estimates suggest that
approximately 3.6 million high school
and middle school students have used
e-cigarettes in the u.s. now ether roots
were originally
created to offer smokers a cleaner form
of nicotine to help with their cigarette
addiction in the u.s. these devices come
under the FDA's jurisdiction as a
tobacco product but the science on these
devices has not been able to keep up
with the rapid market growth so
regulations on the components of these
devices and eliquids are lagging current
regulations do restrict sales of these
devices to anyone under the age of 18
but these do not seem to have had much
of an impact on the explosion in the use
of these devices by teens you know the
first time I heard and soften
e-cigarette I knew right away that teens
would love it
these devices are technology on a stick
a perfect fit for the smartphone
generation small rechargeable easy to
use easy to modify nice-smelling some
even sync with your smartphone to let
you know how much you have vaped even I
was very drawn to these very clever
devices and since I had spent a long
time researching teen and adult
addictions I immediately realized that
these devices fit perfectly into the
teen psyche teens are impulsive and they
love to try new things
they're also craving independence and
they love to make things their own
Easter grits meet these needs perfectly
but allowing them the chance to both
innovate and personalize their reap
experience they can choose from over
15,000 different eliquid flavors and
multiple nicotine concentrations they
can even create their own nicotine
flavor combination they can change how
much vapor is produced from these
devices by modifying the puff volume and
the constituents and the power and
temperature of the devices they can even
use these devices for cloud chasing
cloud chasing also called
vape tricks or small tricks involves
producing large wave clouds with quirky
shapes and names like rings dragons
ghosts cloud chasers can even
participate in cloud competitions and
win prizes
creating the most innovative shaped
clouds teens can also change the
strength and throat it from the vapor by
either vaporizing the e-liquid at higher
temperatures are dripping the e-liquid
directly onto a heated coil they can
even use these devices for marijuana
vaping and since the devices use lower
temperatures and do not combust or burn
the marijuana they can do this very
discreetly without the distinctive smell
of burnt marijuana so they can really
make these vape experiences their own
which may explain the astounding rise in
the use of these devices by youth now e
cigarettes are technically a very simple
device there is a receptacle for the
e-liquid which can be a tank a pod or a
plug there is a battery recharges the
coil which then vaporizes the e-liquid
and then there is a mouthpiece where the
user can actually draw from the
e-cigarette
in 2017 there were 466 a cigarette
devices in the marketplace
these range from cigarette light devices
which are also called cig likes to tank
systems which are also called pens and
then there are modified devices which
are also called mods now mods look
nothing like a cigarette and they come
in various shapes and sizes with
different kinds of attachments and user
adjustments they are very popular for
cloud chasing the most recent entrance
into the marketplace are the pod devices
which contain the e-liquid in a pod
these are very popular by the way among
teens and an example of this is the
Joule which not only looks like a USB
device but can also be plugged into a
USB outlet to charge many teens do not
even think that these are cigarettes
which has led to the use of terms like
dueling instead of vaping many of these
devices are so discreet and produce so
little vapor the teens are using them in
classrooms and hiding them in objects
like Sharpie pens their clothes their
books now many teens think that these
devices produce water vapor and
therefore they are safe to use but this
could not be further from the truth
what is produced is not even a vapor
it's an aerosol and let me tell you the
difference is quite pronounced aerosols
contain many finely suspended particles
of liquids and gases that are created
from whatever is in the e-liquid so an
aerosol could contain propylene glycol
and glycerine which are solvents in the
e-liquid now these solvents are known to
be safe for edible use so for using you
know products that you eat but we know
very little about their safety following
long term inhalational exposure the e
liquids can also contain alcohol
sometimes in high levels and inhaling
alcohol is known to have toxic effects
on the brain I told you earlier that the
liquids contain over 15,000 different
flavors here are some examples somewhat
very catchy but familiar names like
skittles and Froot Loops and others with
more exotic names like Dragon's milk and
Tigers blood and unicorn puck the eel a
liquid or the aerosol can also contain
metallic particles like chromium cadmium
and lead now these are generated from
the heating coil in the devices and are
also known to have many toxic effects on
vital organs so know let me make this
very clear what is produced is
definitely not water vapor exposure of
the teen brain to nicotine through a
cigarettes is also very concerning the
teen brain is very sensitive to even low
levels of nicotine and gets very easily
addicted in fact we have known for a
long time that 90% of smokers start
smoking cigarettes prior to the age of
18 those who start early are more
addicted and have a harder time quitting
smoking in other words and to court an
FDA a passed FDA Commissioner nicotine
addiction is a pediatric disease now
cigarettes can expose teens to a lot of
nicotine many of these devices contain
the amount of nicotine that is in a full
pack of cigarettes the more recent part
devices contain a nicotine salt which
has a smoother taste and is much easier
to use and can produce rapid increases
in brain nicotine levels
teens who use e-cigarettes regularly
report symptoms of craving feeling
anxious when they don't have their east
cigarettes all these are hallmarks of a
behavioral addiction now e cigarettes
not only can are toxic - not are not
only addictive but they also affect many
other organs in the body so nicotine
which is an e-cigarette for example
binds to a receptor called the nicotinic
acetylcholine receptor which plays a key
role in the functioning of almost all
organ systems in the human body and
chronic exposure to nicotine changes the
functioning of these systems so as an
example chronic exposure to nicotine
decreases the flexibility of the blood
vessels and changes how the heart
responds to acute challenges like stress
the teen brain is not only sensitive to
the addictive effects of nicotine but
also to its toxic effects in adolescent
animals nicotine is a very
well-established neurotoxin and it
decreases learning memory and attention
processes and increases hyperactivity
symptoms teens who use tobacco products
are more likely to use marijuana and
alcohol and also develop depression and
anxiety as a team or as an adult so
nicotine addiction through cigarettes
could be leading them down the path of
other addictions and other mental health
problems now in adolescent animals
nicotine also produces epigenetic
changes or heritable changes in gene
expression for example in the genes
involved in asthma so teens who use a
nicotine may not only be harming
themselves but they could be harming
their future generations
you know the very existence of
e-cigarettes could have led to an entire
generation of nicotine addicted youth
easy access to these devices could have
led to more experimentation with
marijuana and many other vaporizer vil
substances by youth while there is no
doubt that providing smokers with the
cleaner form of nicotine is and should
continue to be a critical goal we still
do not know if these devices help
smokers quit smoking and we know very
little about the long-term effects of
these devices
what we do know is that youth lots of
youth are using these devices in fact
the FDA Commissioner recently used the
term epidemic to describe a cigarette
use in the US while trying to solve one
huge public health problem cigarette
smoking we may have created another
colossal one our lack of vigilance in
the earlier years around cigarette
smoking led to a cigarette epidemic and
many many cigarette related diseases we
do not want to repeat the same mistakes
with these cigarettes so now is the time
for action for regulations that address
the appeal and access of these devices
to youth do smokers really need 15,000
kid-friendly flavors to quit smoking
do they need so many different kinds of
devices is it a good idea to have
devices which are so easy to hide and so
easy to use we recently heard that the
FDA plans to introduce stricter
regulations on sales of these devices
that contain illiquid flavors in retail
locations like convenience stores and
gas stations and also introduced
stricter regulations on sales of devices
to minors over the Internet is this
going to be sufficient to change this
rapid increase in youth uptake we need
to ask and answer such critical
questions now is also the time for a
serious public education campaign teams
and their parents need to know that
while each cigarettes may contain less
toxins and cigarettes they are certainly
not benign exposure of their bodies to
the chemicals produced by these devices
could be changing them in ways they may
not like and setting them up for future
unknown toxicities and health problems
you know when I said earlier that
e-cigarettes were a perfect fit for the
smartphone generation I was not kidding
we live in a technology crazed world
where the latest device and technology
gets a lot of attention just because it
is technology and because it is the
latest thing more and more over the next
few years and for the rest of our life
we are going to see technologies coming
into the marketplace that may not raise
any health flags at first simply because
they don't look unhealthy or they're not
a medical device for example we could
see devices that may make it easier to
go longer without sleep or help us lose
weight a personal goal of mine or
achieve any number of other goals that
we as consumers are very very interested
in but many of these devices may come
with unacceptable risks to our own
health so if we want to protect our
health and the health of our children
perhaps we should get out of the habit
of automatically celebrating such new
technology and get into the habit of
looking at them with a critical eye
perhaps even through a medical lens
because you know something our health
the health of our children and our
future generations is far too valuable
to let it go up in smoke or even an
aerosol thank you
[Applause]